now when I sat down with kyla looking on
cinematics the first thing we did on all
of them as we SAT together and we said
what was the intention and so I was like
hey the reason he salutes there or the
reason he kind of hesitates there or the
reason what we were trying to get across
was this now's our time and so Kyle and
I went back through and found places
where we can say oh this is more
meaningful this is more interesting this
is how we would have done it if we had
the time originally
you know our first step in the process
was to sit down and watch everything and
get rods feedback on it really kind of
focus on those key moments that he
wanted to really you know nail so what
we wanted to do was work on Ron's
execution of men there's a lot that went
into that moment and trying to make you
hate rom show his power but and then
transition the power within the squad to
Marcus on all the cinematics for this
year's game we kind of had already a
template in place from the original we
tried to punch up some of the sequences
and storyboarding was kind of integral
to that kind of figuring out what we
wanted to what we want to play up when
we wanted to kind of keep the same we
wanted to get it a lot grittier and that
was really fun Sarge especially from an
animation standpoint because we could
really you know we had these big stunt
guys that came in and picked each other
up and stabbed and like kick him across
the room which was really fun to shoot
the animators had a great time working
on that as well the defen- is really
challenging whenever we get an effect
shot we just want to go in and blow the
person apart but of course with men we
had to be restrained we added more edits
more cuts but try to keep that kind of
documentary handheld style almost like
an opera Ilyich you just it's this gory
scene but it you want to kind of make it
beautiful too so we can get really tight
on characters now we can do full facial
close-ups and get all the subtleties
it's a lot more believable and it's a
lot you know it's definitely grounded
more in reality now so you know even the
details of the wrinkles and the skin
sliding over bone all of those kind of
things really help to sell the emotion
of those characters now when we show
Marcus watching men get executed by rom
we get right up in his face so you can
just kind of see the emotion and its
really believable you know when you look
at chopper crash the original chopper
crash man spends a lot of time kind of
unaware of ROM behind them we had him
like notice sooner and turn
and then try to shoot and try to take on
rom and then rom defeats them even
though we sort of bringing the type you
know smooth this out but also puts more
meaning into men's death but he actually
didn't just get caught by surprise that
he actually saw the threat and attempted
taking it up head-on but still to no
avail we will win this ball it's only a
matter of time